it's incredible
and what was so explain to me what the
process was when these people for this
documentary the skyway bridge disaster
when they came to you were you surprised
or shocked at all within
any of the information that they were
able to uncover
i'm going to say that we came to them
my daughter oh no one knew about you
guys nobody had ever heard about the
d.o.t divers
except our bridge inspection community
yeah our family
the skyway documentary did not no no
disrespect frankie
hear about us before that i contact
contacted them and we had our first
meeting
on june 26th of
2019 the documentary came out in
september
of 2019. so i had just bumped into him
they had put a facebook site up and they
were asking for two stories
i knew we had a true story and i knew
that it was a story that
had never been told because we didn't
tell it
nobody asked nobody asked nobody asked
so we pestered them i pestered them and
pestered them and they finally said
if these guys are for real i imagine we
probably able to interview them
so they uh contacted us we had a meeting
over at derby lane we met with frankie
vanderbo
and introduced ourselves and and i think
it was pretty
pretty plain from frankie that i
provided the documentation that i have
and our expertise and experience and
bridge inspection
on our story but i think pretty much
when i put this picture down
and laid it in front of him i think he
understood
that we were actually out there all of
the most of the people in the
documentary and stuff
there's not too many of them that were
actually there there are a few there's
coast guardsmen and some of the other
people but most of the story
i think we were some of the few people
that were really there
we hadn't had a chance to tell our story
and once frankie heard it
he made sure that we were there i have a
special announcement if you'll allow me
yes please i
am proud to announce that the
documentary
film crew has considered and
are putting together a part two of the
skyway documentary
oh cool they have received reviews
on the amazon site they asked for
reviews and they are listening to the
people that reviewed the documentary
they have taken their people's
questions and are looking to tell more
stories and are
actually putting together a part two
to be out soon if they can complica uh
complete the
the issue but they are going to go ahead
and do a part two on that include more
stories
such as ours so uh hopefully it'll be
out here shortly but i
you know that's a that's an exclusive
for you
interesting man well what what else
would it cover besides i mean obviously
this documentary i feel like it covered
a lot of the story of
um lero the captain and his attorney
and their friendship and kind of like
the misconceptions of him
so the second part you think we'll dive
more into the story
the personal stories what they've done
is they've taken a review
based on the reviews that they've got
and they're going ahead and trying to
answer some of those questions of who
the people want to see
that have seen the the documentary what
they want to hear
so they they're asking more people
probably somebody like the
coast guard people and us maybe would be
included in telling further stories
they're looking
for stories rather than you know just
the
the the accident itself that's
incredible
i'll look forward to it is there
anything else that you guys like to
share before we wrap it up
yeah i'd like to say thanks to a lot of
people there
there are so many people that were out
there that day
that we worked with in in
in past uh that while we were still out
there we worked with the pinellas county
sheriff's department
their bomb squad when we were doing bomb
inspections out there also
we work with the manatee county
sheriff's bomb squad
hillsborough county sheriff's bomb squad
we work with the dive teams
we would like to say thank you to all of
those guys that we didn't have a chance
to
out there that day or the following
months and years
that thing had received several bomb
calls and bomb threats that we were
involved in
uh another one of those things that uh
you know wasn't our job description but
we did it
it was necessary to open it up for
traffic we haven't had a chance to say
thank you
i have a poster similar to the one over
there
that was signed by as many people
that we could muster that were there
that day from pinellas maintenance that
we'd like to go ahead and give to the
dot yard
and say thank you to all those guys who
also haven't had a chance to tell their
story
and and give them that opportunity to at
least be acknowledged and recognized so
we we do have some uh
further plans to give some uh posters
out and say thanks
there are so many people that were
involved
without my faith my family
my friends and the truth there's no
doubt in my mind that it would have been
so much more difficult
to accomplish what we did prior to us
being exposed or coming out by in the
documentary nobody had heard our story
we're not looking for a parade money
or badge or anything like that we're
just trying to set
history straight tell the truth if it's
going to be about the skyway
and we were involved i'd like the truth
to be told and so far i think the
documentary has done a very good job
definitely have to give a shout out to
gabrielle khalis and
and the times for allowing her the
opportunity to spend some time doing
an investigative report that further
solidified and documented
our credibility in regards to this issue
gabrielle did a great job
great job and she and and she really uh
kept us all out of trouble and kept it
as neutral as she could she did a
fantastic job and thanks to the times
even though it took 38 40 years to get
to us
we appreciate the time that we've had
well thank you guys for
sharing your story i'm sure it it takes
a lot to
be able to talk about everything in
detail and
you know i appreciate you guys for all
the hard work and sacrifice that you
guys have made as well
and thanks again for coming on and
telling your story
you